you
why is that terminal as well chess coach
DJ chess dog alright we're ready to go
this is the Estrin tournament that's the
name they give it's a 3o time control 55
minute tournament of Fisher random
chess960 let's put this guy in the
center I think these are this is where I
want the night's night on g3 and maybe
this may be also be for help out my
queen
I may need to take first and then play
c-4 to stabilize my night I could castle
already if I want to definitely need to
get my queen seeing the world Bishop
here I have a lead in development now
Bishop belongs on C to the open D file
should be occupied really soon is this
Knight heading for this square maybe I
should do similar this threatens mate
and maybe this is a way to
cause my opponent some problems maybe
castling would be bad the night gets to
move in there threatening my night
inmate Oh
so let's do this actually I could Castle
queenside queenside isn't bad either
it would be a very long castle but yeah
this rook would end up here not a bad
spot Wow
okay Knight here I'm guessing hmm think
I have to do some
that's ugly or not maybe I could use
that file actually gonna give me the G
file there Knight is unprotected so this
is a this is a possibility they could
long castle as well but they have to
deal with this
ship with an f3 e4 structure this seems
like a pretty purposeful move opens the
bishop opens the rook so let's do it
too much of a good thing everything is
hit boom boom boom g6 e6 d6 all under
file or I'll hunter fire tactical
possibilities on f6
let's take here I'm on e6 cleanest hit
I'm okay with this they're still
uncounseled and they have to do
something drastic
in order to save upon they didn't save
upon they Castle I get the rook whoops
let's try to get in h6 no so this
blasted open now I pressure on f6 to
take I'd have to move this truck to get
activated now we take here we're on c5
with check this drops my rook let's stop
let's go here preparing to get the
Queen's off no no no that's if the rook
played here I'd be so threatening that
clean here is good though
have all week pawns down upon in the
exchange they resign
okay Zhan thoria already has fire -
pretty fast wins for a three out
tournament only five minutes in not even
the chest prince is there I remember the
chess Prince giving me some beatings
with the three check I think I like that
as a first move as well and this this is
going to turn out to be a pretty normal
ish position I think soon let's get the
bishop there and let's put the bishop
here right now
Queen on e7 I think is correct I didn't
quite see that but okay I guess I'm
gonna be alright with giving up my light
square bishop click to support my knight
with that five gorgeous take know I like
supporting gonna go f3
then I'll take okay now this is
something to focus on I'm leaning more
towards castling queenside now that this
files open up mmm
yeah let's let's keep it open over here
Connect rooks no g5 for G for something
like g6
mmm-hmm let's open my bishops eyes for
starters and now this didn't see that
move let's drop the knight in here no no
no they're threatening to take twice
here how about we take here and then
drop this knight in their bishops way
not towards the center I won't play
against this pawn now I have a good
Bishop versus bad bishop idea let's
secure this first and then get to the
e-file probably castle here no I'm okay
with a queen trade yeah let's go for
this definitely taking with the rook I
think I want
bishop on d6
really strong piece from d6 cert some
put some pressure on the kingside I
could look for H 5 H 4 but I probably
want to get my king working a little bit
hmm let's go here let's not go opposite
that rook I think they're preparing to
challenge my rook
can I win this feel like it's too locked
I'm gonna try to convert it
I shouldn't have my Bishop here now good
versus bad bishop actually I do have a
winning idea going all the way over here
maintaining that pawn for sure I think
I'm just gonna mop up that pawn and now
this is completely locked down no
progress over here my king is too fast
keep this pawn around to defend a four
and C form and it's pretty simple from
here this uh if I didn't have my Bishop
here I think it would be even a like I
don't need my Bishop in order for this
to be a draw because they have four
pawns here I think just can't make
progress let's just kill the King I take
like this on e4 and we push him through
H 4 H 3 H 2 no fancy stalemates and
we're getting a queen very soon and
another okay
plenty of time and where's the mate
right there
okay back to tournament got another one
in there 45 minutes left
chickens okay where to start
um I think here both nights here yeah I
want to have all these guys up really
okay let's open my bishops eyes
I may want to go here with my knight I
think I'd like to commit this night
before this one you know
if they tried to do something like this
my knight I'll hop to d5 which would be
a hole so let's go here first
I only need to move my knight in order
to Castle kingside I could already
counsel a queen side if I want
let's get c4 in can't move this pond
these bishops are already developed I
don't need to move my bishops they're
already playing so now looking
four and still not sure where I want my
my knight this is a little bit of a
sensitive square hmm I think I want to
start with d4 and they really should
take otherwise he's dead
it's d5 I'm looking to kill the bishop
with d5 maybe e6 to interfere with this
but still I have enough support for upon
position in Black's territory taking
gives this a half-open file hmm one
minute 12 no Knights jumping straight in
well I have these squares covered let's
let's kill their light square bishop
this is a really nice pawn d5 really
have to be on the lookout for this night
here's something to avoid night here in
Castle kingside
that would be smothered mate we don't
want smothered mate these guys are both
dead and the rook I think I should
I hope they're light-square bishop up
but I could look to play against the
bishop I don't want the position to
become too closed let's take my King
side castle they could take twice here
with some maid idea threat
I'll play it as a gambit if they want to
go for that idea I'm gonna let them I
want this position to open up I should
probably well let's defend here right
now they just move the rook up so they
can't counsel a Kings side they could go
Queen side but it's just a quick switch
of these two my queen should really get
flying
you
let's go h3 they could win a pond but
they've invested a ton of time here yeah
less than 20 okay get some trades in and
I guess one more and maybe snip this guy
here I have this they have a fork they
don't have time not enough gas no
there's another fork but I could get out
of it like that okay no time too much
time span in the middle game there got
eights xanthe Oreo has an eight but
without fire 36 players in this one
okay who is next
oh now this is as close you're gonna get
to regular chess yeah okay
close to looking like regular chests
soon yeah this is gonna be like Sicilian
soon for regular chests
let's make use of the queen position
though to grab some more Queen side
space and I like that she's already here
stopping a night jump probably grab even
more space in the center with the D 5 D
5 Bishop d6 this is a tough this is a
piece that cannot move they didn't find
a way to really coordinate well I don't
think with this Knight here and for me
this was like the first thing that
captured my attention to to try and not
make sure that this awkward night on d8
can do something constructive I may want
to grab some space yeah let's do this
to stop any of this crack open the a
file let's jump up in the center and
look to support him
probably Castle kingside I'm gonna
maintain this tension you know take
towards the center yeah let's take
towards the center King side castle
incoming they should challenge that pawn
really soon not doing that let's just
Castle kingside
he's uh
this Knight has no illegal moves on a
capture my knight would get in here that
would be brutal
imagine a knight right there let's try
four I'm also welcoming a light square
bishop exchange which is desirable
your Bishop and Knight are really
struggling and soon we are gonna have a
night landing d3 this is bad news
taking advantage of pins now focus on f2
Queen f5 all the pieces are coming at
the king now just keep adding fuel there
now let's let's go with the rook first I
don't know where my queen wants to go
just yet
I'll take here only after they work a
little bit to get out of the pin he's
going nowhere he's pinned less than a
minute
Queen exchange I'm fine with that let's
resolve this now let's not resolve that
tension let's just go straight over to
f2 I almost don't even want to take here
because I help out their night alright
let's go there take and here because
maybe I want to take and then take here
forks can't say enough about this guy
right here this past pawn shouldn't
scare me good to pick him up in a couple
meanwhile there's this stuff lined up
I'm just saying
rook g3 and then we have discoveries you
know this should be leading to mate
actually that's a check that's a check
and where's the mate yes well it's just
still here
and I could frame of that it's mate no
matter what next
see for that was the start of some issue
once I planted that pond there and once
I had a pawn on e4 established I think
white needed to be really fast to strike
at that pawn on e4 having space on both
the Kings side and the Queen side was
too much it's difficult enough to work
around those uh space invader pawns just
one of them you know about a couple of a
more present in that game thirty three
minutes left
thirty six players let's have a look at
this one this is a guy in second playing
orbit Ickx I think when I'm paired up
it'll something will pop up to let me
know let me just double check you know
I'm still waiting get paired so let's
check out a game waiting as an Votto is
berserk it's pretty long to get a get up
hearing here you know when you see this
stuff often it's just you move the pawns
in the bishop art and the bishops are
already playing I mean compare that with
regular chess and normally you have to
move a bishop in order to help out your
Brooks but sometimes you know depending
on the initial position the bishops
might not be in the way of the rooks are
some other pieces of the you get the
correct kind of pawn moves in and your
bishops are playing automatically chess
coach okay
this is uh definitely capturing my
attention helps out the rook my knight
will be tucked in right behind King side
Venkat oh let's go here hmm let's go for
an attack h4 h5 they don't have a knight
that can stop this advance so easily see
how they cope with h5 let's follow
through hmm okay actually for the moment
my knight can stay here for a move
neither pawn could chase him away this
Knight is restricted and I'm preparing
to get rid of the dark square bishop but
like you would see you know in a
Yugoslav attack with some kind of a
queen bishop battery but just doing it
from another angle and should he be
captured it's there's a very nice
convenient recapture and developing move
yeah I know
this is to two out of line to do
something like this I have a strong
enough development I think where I can
afford this kind of play I don't see the
position opening up in the center so
much where I could be diverted away from
going out there King some maybe I look
to rattle this Knight position you know
this this seems pretty strong grab some
space and now I'm winning this pawn and
maybe more yeah I'm getting the exchange
I may have mate though actually taking
here and then here is pretty strong cuz
they're in a pin yeah this is this is a
big problem now Bishop takes I could
take with the night and then take the
rook okay I'm up a full rook now
anything better let me go here I want to
take this rook just to force their King
to an awkward Square yeah
and now probably night here eyeing up
these two let's go G three Bishop H
three there in a pin let's go here to
stop Knight d4 I don't want to even see
one of their pieces post up in my
position
it's a strong night but I just want to
get my Bishop here get my queen in
towards the action right now that's the
last that's a newly weakened square whoa
I was ready just drop my queen oh that
would have been bad that would have been
really really bad it's a good thing it
wasn't touched move Johnny deejay 3:16
in the chat said UV orbit Ickx I guess
you trying to help me out well done
let's go here
this move can be met with Queen c5
getting out of the fork where's that
Queen going I may still do this you know
let's do it get a queen trade in there I
am up a rook actually if I do this I'm
dropping the bishop but still
either way okay now the night s to move
let's improve the King don't allow any
rook activity box out the knight take on
h5 push the knight anything at this
point we're entering no time for the
coach scoop that pond up there down on
time back to tournament Seventeen's and
vato who lost his first yeah we played
in round one but since then he has been
berserk exam all right what kind of
configuration we have here he probably
wants to go there I like this
on in the center rook has support for it
likely a good start let's commit my
knight he knows his place the vicious
where do they want to go how are we
gonna open up this position how about
this move in an f4 all right I'm
starting to see how they could come out
pretty naturally okay that's a good move
interfering with my f4 idea
let's put a night out yeah I can look
for this idea now
Night Moves we get the dark square
Bishop Soph copycat so far it's uh if
they do this it's symmetrical each of us
have a lot of control over the f5
squares f4 f5 I'm not sure which way to
castle let's start with this hit the
bishop you know if I can take this
bishop out then if the rook captures
they could only Castle queenside the
King captures I know where the King's
gonna be do I really want to take the
dark square bishop I don't know uh I
think I like queenside castle start here
if the bishop goes here maybe I'm okay
with allowing them to capture me because
I would have control over f4 and here
okay now I'm going to take they've
weakened their dark squares some
queenside castle seems correct and now
we can look for a push maybe could have
inserted Knight f5 feel like I want to
challenge this Knight let's do that
mm-hmm okay now I'm going back here
that's a weakness and I can kick the
night away with g3 now this is
unprotected but I don't see how they
could really get it get at it so easily
how to recapture okay so they could only
Castle queenside let's open up the
position right now all right in the
center get the Queen
active she's maybe my worst place piece
right now let's get the Queen rolling
these are two useful moves 83 King be
one King be one maybe first they still
can't counsel the this rook this uh
Brooke needs to be off of that square
let's get another useful move in now I
could jump in they gave up that Square
and now kick the knight next for the
moment though let's just not give up any
squares just yet
I want to flush their night away they've
masked their queen right there scooped
up upon this now might be a pretty good
square let's kick the night away first
and I could win another pawn with this
push getting this guy he
take him out and I'd like to take this
guy out so he's a passed pawn I'll let
this pawn kill the knight less than 40
Knight nf5 it's a really strong Bishop
under 30 hmm all right let's take the
knight and let's take I don't want to
help their Queen out okay their Knight
is pretty strong blockading this guy so
let's go here okay on c5 let's just
support my F pawn get a flight Square
secure my queen
defend my pawn I could take here let's
just defend everything first rook there
wow that's a really no okay I have to
block let's get pushing one rock off
could take here have this square covered
where's the mate
time I didn't play that well at the end
but I had an eye on the clock there 20
and change 27 is in first as an vato
let's see who we get 38 players DJ Ches
dog is on my heels who's next okay Alex
yo Dana probably want this but my only
concern is can I get this and move in
first I think I could get away with that
maybe he goes here actually hmm yeah
let's go here I want to get my knight
here soon
I think I played it wrong they could
have played this move sooner and I may
have been in trouble let's go a night
here good look to I up this square mmm
let's get the Queen up d5 they're
probably ready to do that and d5 96 into
e4 a5 a4 see how they maybe flinch give
up some squares possibly this Knight is
struggling he needs to be able to make
use of this square he's dead on that
square let's put the night here he's not
needed to watch over these two okay
let's let's Castle kingside
and maybe see five let's get c5 in maybe
take this square away I should have
maybe gone for this much sooner it's
gonna be quite annoying though if the
knight goes here this pin let's do it
yeah
doing this to take away that square now
let's return here they have every piece
on that I guess they could push huh okay
okay I'm gonna bypass
it take yeah let's take once this pond
is killing so many of their pieces let's
take and now what to do you know these
pieces are all killed by this pond
really I have a night move with an
attack against the rook so my concern
though is night here there's Bishop
takes and then on Bishop takes rook
there's Bishop check
well I don't need to move my night let's
go here stop this move rook here yeah
they're probably realizing right around
now that this pawn is a giant giant pest
once these rooks are gone I didn't even
see that move oh okay they can't go here
just yet not right here right now isn't
so much of a bother they're running into
some pins bishop pair i think should
still be enough their night i think will
struggle for the rest of the game let me
first get this in though just so the
bishop doesn't try to sneak out you know
let's go by giving them a passed pawn
but i have soon to I'm soon to have a
passed pawn and also now this pawn
doesn't have so much support and will be
quite a difficult to upon to defend no
yeah he's ready to go into pac-man modem
connected passed pawns without the beep
on you know this is gone now I think
just like that take take try to get my
beep on ok they're on my ruck take and
probably just push more probably have to
give up their minor piece around here
hey yep now improve the king let's stop
this pawn from going any further for
starters let's improve my king 27
seconds also I just dropped his pawn oh
good grief and my bishop Wow definitely
lost the thread there huh I'd say I need
to keep a tricky night around no boy can
I get that pond
oh they're going too fast
it's the right color bishop whoa
oh it's still me oh man still me that's
a killer man ah ah
they had stalemate they're a stalemate
trick not cool I had so much control
over that position I threw it away I was
losing and then I was winning and then I
was losing no winning losing winning and
then in the end of draw ah man just a
bishop move first
mm man ok 13 minutes and change this
guy's running away with it got paired in
round 1 and he's been on a tear since
he's flying right now let's have a look
at this pack leader so strong Knight
he's got there
last opponent was playing really fast
they kicked it into a higher gear
okay
this night is still very very good on c5
hmm where is he going
repetition not even close
alright I'm not paired up yet just
double-checking no it's off positioned
away two three four five six seven yeah
ooh that's trouble could do this and
kind of lock down on the king maybe I I
think it's waiting for this game to
finish and maybe I'm gonna get paired up
with him is that what's happening
maybe mate I think we're gonna get
paired up yeah we get paired up with the
pack leader again you don't get paired
if you watch a game no that's not true
I'm pretty that's not true
okay okay get my night out yeah
the one that I should have probably
thought a bit more about my light-square
bishop hmm let's go here first they're
gonna have a nice Center soon aren't
they
let's strike in the center first I can
support my center with Knight c7
let's grab some space space invader
Bishop here I'm okay with this Bishop
check you're gonna help me to develop
yes let's break that pin immediately I'm
leaning more towards queenside castle
yeah let's go Queen side let's put my
bishop here should be a nightmare now
let's get this rook active first b5 be
for isn't out of the question
let's get this in this is a blunder so I
could take trade Queens and then there's
no longer enough defense on f5 Oh
however I am dropping this pawn ah man
not cool and maybe more maybe yeah
that's a pretty significant pawn I'd say
oh that's all it takes
another night hmm
their queen is too annoying well to
somehow work
some magic I really don't know how to do
that though I think I have to get rid of
their queen
too strong take with the bishop I guess
try to play against f3
hmm okay well he's the new target and
let's post up let's defend upon maybe
let's hang onto a pond this time
okay let's demote the night and stop him
from getting into the ball game
okay I think they should have got to the
open file soon sooner than they did okay
I have an active rook but that's about
it I feel like I should be able to hold
this to a draw should
let's see though
Jack I need to stay active with my rook
all right I guess - an open file let's
go for B for my king stops there extra
pawn they're going a bit astray with
that I might be close to winning now
that they captured I think it is winning
yeah I'm getting this their king is just
out of play now yeah
got a passed pawn and I'm no longer down
any material with my next move their
King went astray
ah
yeah he is way out of play here push
no I'll be there in time my rock will
get behind I'm striking first situ came
here and no no no no I want to take here
right now all right I want to go here
right now I think and then take and
defend this guy now we do this now we're
in time right here and we got him okay
definitely didn't work all that out but
I felt like I'd be there in time
no stalemates this time back determine
4125 DJ chest dog over took the second
spot
he doesn't have fire chairman oil okay
let's get try and get one more game in
maybe I could sneak one more in to
guarantee a second place spot if I get
this win let's
see for
okay are they gonna move
they are gonna move and their IT mm-hmm
bit questionable the night move Space
Invaders it's like a Kings Indian here
comes the night I know where he belongs
right here he's really strong mm-hmm
let's be aggressive I'm giving up this
square but they're not they're not there
to make use of it let's get the bishop
out I'm gonna Castle queenside so I need
to move these two in order to do that
yeah
Queen side here comes the Queen side
castles hmm 215
there we go king b1 rook C 1 C 5 is a
nice pawn break get it there King he
should look to jump into F for not doing
that I want to be prepared to just
support e4 c5 I want to keep control
over this square these guys are kind of
all dead because of the structure alone
let's keep this pawn around the bishop
takes is fine Queen is only has one
square gonna play Knight b5 just to
provoke some kind of pawn move and then
I'm fine with going to the edge just so
I could get c5 and next my bishop
controls this so tough to even contest
any out at the C file pressure that's a
right around the corner pieces are just
kind of swarming in now crashing through
there and where is the mate let's drift
over here trying to take a couple times
with the fork I'm just winning a knight
now 227 they won't be able to just time
burn their way okay I'm getting the rook
I'm not going to take it though I feel
like this is
somehow better keeping a knight around
where's the mate let's go here first put
a knight on e5 let's grab this pawn on
the rook I know they missed that should
be mate in a few all right let's hit the
bishop already 122 on the game clock
let's just get a queen
and I want to move this
because then they moved the veep on just
get rid of him I could take that guy 55
seconds main to threat and there we go
got the mate oh he berserk
oh I'm not getting four that's right I
didn't have fire because uh I said yeah
I wasn't on streak there I was thinking
I was getting gift for so even berserk
King that last one wasn't bad enough so
DJ chest dog beat me out for the third
spot and who knows maybe I don't even
get third house terminals game looking
hurry up game clock tournament clock 15
seconds don't finish terminal whatever
you do don't finish it's even in a game
now he's not playing three two and one
that's gonna do it 43 players in this
one a 960 tournament one of my favorite
variants zanbato first if 44 and DJ
chess dog 30 I'm in there at 26 and
right on my heels terminal orbit ticks
and see everyone else
let's see page two three four and five
already to the 42 of you
the games all alright